[Musik]
Abenteuer kilimancharo präsentiert von
Edelweiß
[Musik]
8 Tage 76 km und fast 6000
Höhenmeter das Dach
Afrikas drei Frauen und drei Männer
erfüllen sich ihren Lebenstraum ein
Tracking auf den
5895 hohen kilimjaro eine
Herausforderung mit vielen
[Musik]
Hürden ein kolossales
Erlebnis aber was
ma he
hetig die alle an ihre Grenzen
[Musik]
BRT der kilimandaro liegt in Tansania er
ist der höchste Berg
Afrikas an seinem Fuß liegt die kleine
Streusiedlung
marango
diese sechs Menschen aus der Schweiz
Wagen das
Abenteuer
kurlin organisiert seit 35 Jahren Trips
auf den Kilimanjaro und führt die
Neuankömmlinge in seine zweite Heimat
[Musik]
ein
K
organisieren das H
natürlich
nicht ganz so
[Musik]
intensiv extrem schnell ist Gang mit
total überrascht thank you
[Musik]
noch die sechs kennen sich erst seit
einem Tag das einzige was sie verbindet
ist ihr gemeinsames
Ziel
[Musik]
ho Baby oh jetzt pink
pink der G
[Musik]
sich
wür ich jetzt
[Musik]
finden der erste Tag ist
akklimatisierungstag marango liegt auf
1800 m über Meer die meisten Einwohner
leben
vomourismus Markt trifft Bergführer
priskus Peter die letzten Vorbereitungen
für das atägige
Tracking mit dabei sein Küchenchef
Eduard und seine Frau
Lucy wir brauchen Gemüse und Früchte
etwa 40
Kil wir sind eine große
Gruppe auch die filmw muss verpflegt
werden das sind acht Leute zusätzlich
Gemüse wird das Hauptnahrungsmittel sein
in den nächsten
Tagen alle Träger die ganze Kuh am Berg
die habe ich
angeheuert wenn etwas fehlt z.B Essen
schauen alle mich
an wenn den Kunden etwas fehlt schauen
auch alle
mich ich binwlich
füres für dieä habe genügend
Lebensmittel für die Kunden genügend
Zelte für alle so es alle genießen
können auch Früchte dürfen nicht
fehlen wenn ich Schweizer habe kaufe ich
Mangos und Ananas ich weiß die mögen das
sehr die Gruppe in marango deckt sich
mit Coca-Cola ein ein Tipp von Kurt
falls der Magen Probleme
macht
viele Fragen und frühliche Nervosität
alle haben ein anderes Motiv warum sie
den kilimanaro besteigen
wollen Afrika mag will ich ja mal auf
Dach Afrika will will ich dir Challenge
hö mal selber weg spüren und jaum lang
drin das J bin ich gerade umbruchase und
und es freut mich mega D D der trumlich
dar ERF ich we das
soens Challenge ist sicher einmalig im
Le macht und W sicher Granze und ganz
schöne Sache geseht hoffe mir
auch W m dasand vom komplett GEW Altag
ich be ich wandere sehr gern
so reichbar für mich ja nicht so gern
also so Schnee mit undel nicht so mi und
K so machbar so eine lange so hö wander
machen ich noch nie und bin gespannt ob
es geht und
ja alle s immer Po langsam langsam das
wir Motto von der Woche wer
glaub
Hakuna Matata alles kein Problem auch
das wird ein Motto werden in diesen
Tagen alle sechs haben sich auf einen
Aufruf von SRF gemeldet und bezahlen
ihre Reise
selbst wie sag
da sie wollen auch mehr über ihre
Begleiter am Berg
und das heißt ein du ver gut das G ja es
gut aber du bra Arbeit Konkurrenz extrem
groß du h h
ge
vielleichtit Kur hat lange mit prisk
Vater gearbeitet der wiederum hat seinen
Sohn
naenor
J Vater gestorben ist ist er das
Familienoberhaupt und muss für seine Zeh
Geschwister sorgen auch für seine
Schwester Brigit sie hat sich spontan
entschlossen die Tour
mitzumachen Lucy und priskus haben drei
Söhne die zwei älteren sind auf einer
Privatschule priskus ist privilegiert
als leitender Bergführer verdient
er50 pro
trip we ich auf den kilimanaro
gehe meine Familie ist gesund weil ich
Touren mache und so Geld
verdiene das ist alles nur wegen dem
kilimanaro Morgen gehen wir hoch auch
meine Nachbarn kommen mit als
Träger das hilft Ihnen sie profitieren
auch davon und können so ein anständiges
Leben
führen zusätzlich noch unterstützt hat
es bisher weder für den Innenausbau noch
für die Fenster
[Musik]
gereicht die Gruppe ist ins Hotel
zurückgekehrt more than a job ist eine
Schweizer NGO die jungen Frauen aus
zerrütteten Verhältnissen eine
Ausbildung in der Hotellerie ermöglicht
sie wohnen hier lernen Englisch und wie
man serviert und sich gegenüber Gästen
verhältisus und sein Bruder Augustin
sind fürs Briefing
gekommen gen Abend
zusammen wie geht
euch alles
okay F weitere mit insgesamt sind wir
sie
geid das ist Brigit meine Schwester sie
wird uns begleiten Schritt für Schritt
auf das Dach
afrikasus gibt Tipps wie man es am
besten schafft auf den Gipfel zu
kommen trinkt
genügerhe die schnell rauf wollen
bekommen Probleme denn ihr Körper hat
nicht genügend Zeit um sich an die Höhe
zu
gewöhnen einige Leute schaffen es nicht
auf den Gipfel weil sie zu viel
denken also bleibt immer
optimistisch ohne Fleis kein
Preis der letzte Tag auf dem Weg zum
Gipfel ihr fühlt euch müde euch ist
schwindlich ihr habt Kopfschmerzen alles
nervt und euch ist
schlecht das ist alles sehr
normaluu eine klare
Ansage priskus Bruder Augustin übernimmt
den
gepäckcheck
ho
che
sleeple
[Musik]
per ich früh wahsinnig schnell und
bin
temperat
yes
zwei zaht aber halt ja
dafür sicher bin D alles funktioniert
Therm sch
schmeck die meisten Leute nehmen zu viel
mit vor allem
waren sie denken es GBE nicht genügend
zu essen am Kilimanjaro und packen darum
zu viele Snacks ein dann ist ihr Gepäck
zu
schwer
hi yes very yes yes yes so can I check
the equipment please yes you W start
with sand okay
SRA my Unicorn is veryimportant for the
summit you make not forget it on the sum
no no this is my my
K
speziell
dass mit
Wasser
[Musik]
endlich geht's los D Stunden Busfahrt
bis zum Start am leemoscho
[Musik]
Gate besteigt den Kilimanjaro in 8 Tagen
und überwindet dabei gesamthaft fast
Höhenmeter vom Gate geht es in den
ersten drei Tagen zum Big Tree Camp im
Dschungel dann zum sheira Camp one und
von dort über die sogenannte Kathedrale
zum Shira Camp
2 am vierten Tag geht es auf den Lava
Tower und wieder hinunter zum baranco
Camp von dort über die Bar
zum
Kanga und zum barfu
Camp von wo aus schließlich der Aufstieg
auf den uhuruak
beginnt die Lemos Route ist die längste
am Kilimanjaro für nicht akklimatisierte
aber die sicherste weil der Körper sich
wegen der vielen auf und Abstiege
langsam an die Höhe gewöhnen
kannereit viel
los
priskus instruiert seine
Träger für die 8 Tage am Berg hat er 45
Träger
angeheuert dre pro
Person das sind unsere Träger sie müssen
in einer Reihe
stehen später bevor wir starten haben
wir dort drüben eine Waage
sie müssen Ihr Gepäck wägen Sie dürfen
nicht mehr als 20 kg
tragen priskus hat alle seine Bekannten
aufgeboten jeder Träger verdient 15 am
Tag die Jobs sind heiß
begehrt wenn sie zu wenig Touren haben
sind sie sehr traurig ich auch wenn ich
nicht genügend Jobs habe bin ich
gestresst aber wenn ich genügend Touren
habe etwa zwei bis dre jeden Monat in
der Hochsaison dann kann ich mich
entspannen wir sind zu 100% von diesem
Job
abhängig hello
hello
welcomeat welcome welome
welcome welcome
Name 190 W long time
AG
priskos Bruder Augustin hilft beim
Wägen das ist die
Waage wenn Sie hier Wägen sind es
manchmal mehr als 20 Kil dann nehmen Sie
etwas raus erst dann dürfen sie
gehen ob Zelte Schlafmatten
Küchenutensilien oder Esswaren alles
muss kontrolliert richtig verpackt und
hochgragen
werden alle müsen sich bekung
isten zahlen eine parkgebüh
von00 ich schö Einheit
oder Angst
lustig
das
schön
auf Landschaft das
macht g nwen Berg und das find die nicht
so gut wenn man nurwen Berg die Reis
macht es ist ja so viel rundch oder die
schön Landschaft sie und wie sie sind
und ja ja das macht so viel
SRA zu wichtig oder ich danke
sie und wenn
nicht ke
[Gelächter]
gut und
genau das Gepäck wird schon
hochtrportiert die dar noch nicht
los
gelaufeniskus verhandelt mit der
parkverwaltungch Park ich
glaub
[Musik]
higkeitamp
genau Schw langsam die schnell
laufenkverwtung alle Hebel
inwegung
[Musik]
dauert was wenn alle Stricke
reißen aber was machen
ist
ge und Trager wieder ab
schicken für sie würde trink
größilind
aber das braen zum Schlafen da ist klar
[Musik]
dasf eine halbe Stunde
später ja freig
überrasch
nach 4er Stunden warten
endlich das Abenteuer kann beginnen es
ist
4:30 bis zum ersten Camp sind es knapp
700 Höhenmeter und 3 Stunden
[Musik]
Marsch als Landwirtin hat Ursula ein
besonderes Auge für die
Natur
jetztch das
das hier s aber
ich
was bis jetzt ganz gut ich merke dass
wir schon auf s gestartet sind schon
z4lich mit Lauf ST s aber ganz
gut
got
[Musik]
istu
Rockstar unglaublich das finde ich
extremücklich wie sie
jetzt
daeh weg und der Ruh
ausstrahl wirklich richtig Spektakel da
de
[Musik]
Platz mega berührt V dem ganz ich gar
nicht gerechnet ja ja es ist mega schön
jaü
richtig
Gent danke
[Gelächter]
auf St Pflücker so B
[Musik]
schön es ist Stil
ja no
mag
doch also ich muss schon nicht immer so
steil und ich bin froh wenn man nicht
auch zu lange im dunkler m Lauf schon
nicht Favorit drum versuche jetzt noch
gerade
B das
[Musik]
schn
das Big Tree Camp auf
m das machen
wir noch nicht
gefunden glaub da Kön
sie
ja
[Musik]
genauagh Grupp
mit
aber hier s
Mens ze D
dieop gemacht ist
Spektakel Familie mit
Baby wirklich zum kN ich glaub das ist
wir die durchschliche
cingerfahrung das
längste und ke mit dem Bus aber das ist
ja das ist
komfortabl
ja
aber das zeht auch ganz komfortabel aus
da ich bin wirklich Stum mich s alles
aufbaut und Matratze li drin werden nur
zum zT geführt D das ist topsice ja top
service was die L machen
find
ja kurt hat den Berg mindestens 50 Mal
bestiegen er fühlt sich zu Hause Zeit
für ja
mus ja
LUN
cool
tageded was mich sehruckt die
Unruhe unsicher sind
kom und die erste kabusm geh das ein R
Gruppe und ist alles so fast meditativ
worden sorry
und das ist vorstellen das ist neue R
das ist früh vor jah
ist und
so ne gemacht examit interessante
R gut ist
zumlimatisieren das
ist für die Gruppe wo wir da sind
ja oder so aber nicht nur dass
dann also du mus für jeden Schlafplatz
und für
jeden expon ja genau Kuren unglaublich
das stimmt das ist so dass sie einfach
nur re das großes das S nur ugal quasi
und
kisay und so sie wenigerwicht
mitess und sind einam und sie Kön sie
sind Schw l aber sie D nochch wir essen
und wenn wir gessen sie
essen Wahnsinn ja ja die sind soksam ja
ja der GAP zwischen Touristen und Träger
ist augenfällig und wird ein Thema
bleiben am ersten Abend aber sind alle
zu müde für tiefgründige
Diskussionen gleich nach dem Nachtessen
ist Nachtruhe gut
Nacht
am nächsten Morgen kurz vor 7 es ist
gerade einmal 4°
warm sich schon bessere Nacht aber wir
nicht schleach schwierig sie zum
Temperatur regulieren irgendwie wirdfror
noch wieder
he
aber ganz okay
ja
[Applaus]
W bis mor so schlimm ja so schlimm
schlimm is Schwester Brigit musste
gestern vor Erschöpfung Weinen jetzt
geht es ihr wieder
gut
Morgenprogramm für dringende Bedürfnisse
gibt es zwei blaue
wczelte
[Musik]
sandra hatte sich mit Permanent Makeup
einfach
gemacht das die
ganz schm
gar wennvival machen bra das nicht
und
G
gen absolut ke Problem mal gesichtsc mit
gefunden son l die F und lippom
eent ich gerade dass die daü sind mit
Rier
und
ja
[Musik]
Uhr Wanderung liegen vor
ihnen ich muss noch bleiben um zu
schauen dass hier alles aufgeräumt ist
und stoße dann im Busch zu
euch gute
[Musik]
Wanderung vom Big Tree Camp geht's 10 km
und 900 höhenm zum Shira Camp one auf
3500 m
[Musik]
oh K stempe da ganz
andere Vegetation für Klaus ist trecken
etwas Neues es ist das erste Mal
überhaupt dass der Anästhesist und
regerarzt ohne seine Familie Ferien
macht ist ein so viel
wo oder und mer tut extrem gut dass ich
mal aus dem Wahnsinn durorganisierte
Alltag durstrukturierten Alltag das
man kommt und mal wieder ganz anders
machen kann und und so
richtigeus ist ein Familienmensch und
sch
verheiratet die Kinder ändert sich
einiges schon das crisis ich
weiß so sind jetzt die sind jetzt 18 das
J ist 15 der jetztus also sind plötzlich
all kind aus der Schul es ist g schon so
B unbruch oder viicht das nach all deine
Jahre vi Moment wo man sich überle okay
möch nochend in Neu richtig oder and im
Le BU Vich Challenge im Le vor einem
Jahr hat Klaus darum die Konsequenzen
gezogen im Spital gekündigt und sich
selbständig gemacht seither arbeitet er
als anäthesist auf Abruf in prachsen und
spitäl und ist sein eigener
Chef priskus Schwester Brigit
kämpft es ist anstrengend ich habe wenig
Übung aber es tut
gut ich bin so stolz auf meine Brüder
die hier am schuften sind und meinen
Vater im Himmel dass sie das machen für
mich und für uns damit wir eine gute
Ausbildung
haben mit all den Lasten auf den
Schultern sie alle sind
Superhelden
sch
wow
[Musik]
n der Shir bildet mit dem Kibo und der
mai zusammen das Kilimanjaro massiv der
Kibo ist mit
5895 m der höchste Punkt dort wollen
alle hin schon dre Stunden ist die
Truppe unterwegs
Ursula nimmt
gemütlich sie arbeitet viel draußen und
ist körperliche Anstrengung
gewohnt auf den Killi wollte sie schon
als ihre Kinder noch klein
waren erwte g nicht die hab generell
abgestellt es tut mir
vielrück Horizont K man dem sagen und es
ist für mtig
Ding istlebnis oder w jetzt DF machen
und das ist Freud vom
ganz auch wenn sie zu Hause viel wandert
hier geht es nicht so einfach wie sie
gedacht
hatü
also geh
muss einfach
langsam
aber
und
sch
sch ja das geh
Sch Ursa hat ihr Leben vor z Jahren
radikal verändert sie hat sich scheiden
lassen und ist aus dem gemeinsamen Haus
ausgezogen ihre zwei Mädchen sind
erwachsen nun hat sie Zeit die Welt neu
zu entdecken es ist so vieles offer für
m ja g schon v re irendwie gar nicht
merk dass noch gar nicht
Gang ja es es h sich ja vorher mitchaff
und Spaß geh ist
wirklich ganz
vielgang wo ich ausprobi oder w ich vi
wieder zu nicht passt extrem
fr jede und jeder läuft sein Tempo auf
dem Shira Plateau ist die Gruppe
zeitweise Kilometer weit auseinander
doch überall ist ein geid in der Nähe
falls etwas
wäre Damaris hatte vor einigen Jahren
massive Rückenprobleme unvorstellbar
damals ein solches treacking in Angriff
zu
nehmen schon
mitum und ich den irgendwn schon wieder
ab und zu Hintergrund Gerat und in der
letzte Jahr hab ich wander wieder so für
mir entdeckt undemkt beim wander so
me der
Berg die ist s steht an einem völlig
anderen Punkt im Leben als die anderen
gerade hat sie ihr Studium abgeschlossen
und genießt ihre
Unabhängigkeit ich versuche mega fest im
Moment und so wie es gerade ist und wenn
der mal Bezi wir den N dirin richtige
ist und wenn nicht ich kann ich dafür
ganz viel anders machen W ich vielleicht
nicht WD machen und das das glaubo mir
ganz vi lef geh s nicht immer verpassen
sondern J die Möglichkeit im
Le ja B mir mega schöns
[Musik]
und imir Camp arbeiten die Träger
bereits wieder auf Hochturen
verantwortlich für alles was mit
übernachten und essen zu tun hat ist
Augustin briskos
Bruder das sind die Camping Manager sie
müssen schnell laufen können damit sie
alles vorbereiten können für die
turouristen wer zuerst kommt hat den
Platz es gibt keine parkregel sie sagen
zwar sie lassen nicht mehr als 200 Leute
rein pro Tag aber es gibt keine Buchung
darum weiß man
nie manchmal kommen 300 da kann man
nichts machen man kann sie ja nicht
zurückschicken und wir mögen es wenn
viele Touristen
kommen fast wie im Hotel das Gepäck wird
aufs Zimmer gebracht jede und jeder
bekommt eine
Matte
als erste ist Sandra
angekommen
super cool Wander
und das so gut gegangen
istimf noch eine schwatze minand
und wirklich super Gang hat
nicht weiß es nicht noch nicht da
also
die schne sag jetzt mal sind schon da
und die wo sind
[Musik]
laufen
gut ich bin also ich
würde das letzte steile ST bin
ich
so
da vi nicht ja viicht
endlich haben die Träger Pause alle
Essen Ugali ihren
Maisbrei das ist unser hatnrungsmittel
am
Berg er soll für die Träger Pasta kochen
schätzen sie das
nicht wir mögen UG das macht
stark Moment überhaupt nicht vorstellen
wo das
nach
Dasch die
K Horizont oder
steil fif
gradef die sind wirklich ma jetzt sehr
gutruck mit locker und so ja gut gut
Gefühl aber es heißt noch nicht wir sind
erst Tag
2 natürlich das schon
anders jetzt zeigt
sich
Schnee Afrika hab sch unvorstellbar
dass
mein
wir
tagech
sindch
der Berg das erste Mal in seiner vollen
Pracht sech Tage liegen noch vor ihnen
werden sie es schaffen und was hat es
mit Ursulas Beschwerden auf
[Musik]
sich
Abenteuer kilimancharo präsentiert von
Edelweiß